men and women cannot be best friends
especially when you're married married
people can't have friends you're not
married then you know that's maybe part
of the courting process and all that but
when you're married you should not have
close friends who are of the opposite
sex you're just asking for this it's
what you it's like you're literally
asking for you might as well ask for it
out loud that doesn't mean that you
can't have Associates or people that you
work with people you're friendly with
and all that sort of thing it doesn't
mean that uh you know if you're married
and a person of the opposite sex walks
into the room you got to run out of the
room screaming no one is saying that but
to have a close friend have someone you
describe as a best friend of the
opposite sex when you're married is well
on your way to an affair already